the one ring is an incredibly powerful
card offering both card draw and
protection it slots into nearly every
commander deck there is so let's go over
12 mostly budget Commander cards that go
with the one ring
before we start let's quickly go over
the card and some key things you need to
know to both use and counter that
powerful protection ability
okay
so the one ring is a four Mana legendary
artifact with indestructible that says
when the One Ring enters the battlefield
if you cast it you gain protection from
everything until your next turn
at the beginning of your upkeep you lose
one life for each bird encounter on the
One Ring and finally tap put a burden
counter on the One Ring then draw a card
for each bird encounter on the One Ring
poor what a card so we need to take note
of some key things here firstly that
protection ability only triggers when
you cast the One Ring putting it into
play with cards like master transmuter
or refurbish will not trigger it however
cards that say you may cast or play this
card will for example Reckless impulse
it doesn't matter where the card is cast
from as long as you actually cast it and
put it on the stack
second thing
protection from everything technically
doesn't mean protection from everything
here's what the rules say a permanent or
player with protection from everything
has protection from each object
regardless of that object's
characteristic values
such a permanent or player can't be
targeted by spells or abilities and
can't be enchanted by auras and all
damage that would be dealt to such a
permanent or player is prevented
so let's take a look at this combo you
might see someone try to pull off with
the one ring
aside from the one ring there's only one
other card needed and a card like Grand
abolisher to stop your opponents from
activating abilities or casting spells
during your turn
so that one card you need for this combo
is lethal Vapors a four Mana black
enchantment that says whenever a
creature enters the battlefield destroy
it and pay zero destroy lethal Vapors
you skipped your next turn any player
May activate this ability
so with lethal Vapors in Play We cast
the one ring and get its protection
trigger which as a reminder says you
gain protection from everything until
your next turn
but what if we never had another turn
let's say we activated lethal Vapor's
ability one million times well now we
would have protection from everything
for effectively the rest of the game or
until everybody decked themselves or
gets bored and leave
but you can still kill a player with
protection from everything
while protection from everything does
prevent targeted spells and damage being
dealt it doesn't stop non-targeted
poison counters such as prologue to fire
recess and because the proliferate
ability doesn't Target you can
proliferate a protection from everything
player until they have 10 poison
counters and they lose the game
also spells like Stomp the two Mana
instant half of Bone Crusher giant says
damage can't be prevented this turn and
abilities such as questing beasts combat
damage that would be dealt by creatures
you control can't be prevented can allow
you to break through that barrier and
finish the protection from everything
player with creature damage
finally let's talk about that card draw
ability in Commander paying one life for
one card is an extremely good deal and
the fact that we effectively get an
advance on that deal by not paying life
until the start of our next turn makes
it even better so of course we're going
to find a way to abuse this
so right out of the gates let's get one
of the non-budget cards out of the way
you can draw your whole Deck with a
single enchantment from Exodus Mind Over
Matter
tap the ring to draw a card then discard
a card to mind over matter to untap the
ring and then simply rinse and repeat to
draw the rest of your deck
so clearly the best thing to do here is
to untap the one ring as many times as
we can during a turn
for Budget options we've got some of my
favorite budget artifacts the first two
are just all round good artifacts so
even if you don't get the One Ring
they're still probably worth picking up
let's check out clock of Omens and the
unwinding clock
of Omens is a four minor artifact that
says tap two untapped artifacts you
control untap Target artifact
so to put it simply you can tap any
combination of artifact creatures blood
tokens Treasures or other artifacts to
power up your ring my personal favorites
to tap are storage Matrix and Howling
mind as you can make it so only you reap
the benefits from those cards just by
tapping them with clock of Omens
unwinding clock is just effectively a
Seaborn Muse for artifacts see ball Muse
is an incredibly powerful card and I'm
surprised the artifact version doesn't
see more play in the right deck this
card is an absolute Powerhouse unwinding
clock is another four minor artifact
that lets you untap all of your
artifacts during each player's untapped
step
combine that with clock of Omens and the
one ring and you might just draw your
deck before the start of your next turn
two other artifacts you should look to
put in your artifact decks if you
haven't already are the two keys voltaic
key and manifold key both are one Mana
artifacts that have pay one tap untap
Target artifact manifold key also has
the additional utility to make a
creature unblockable
both of these Keys have lots of utility
outside of just working with the One
Ring you can use the keys on your minor
rocks to generate a little bit more Mana
you can give one of your artifact
creatures a pseudo vigilance ability do
not underestimate the power of these
keys
two more brilliant one ring Synergy
cards we need to mention are the dalkin
orery and Shimmer
the dalkin Ori is a four minor artifact
that gives all our artifacts Flash and
Shimmer does the same thing but for
three mana on a 2-2 body and shimmerman
also has flash itself
so of course being able to give the One
Ring flash is incredible when someone
swings for lethal damage at us simply
flash in the one ring and prevent all
the damage unless of course they have a
questing beast
moving slightly away from artifacts
we've got some creatures that pair
excellently with the one ring the
necrons from the Warhammer 40K Commander
decks absolutely love artifacts and the
two we're looking at today are extremely
budget friendly too
first up we have trasin the infinite
this six Mana four six has death touch
and Prismatic Gallery as long as trazin
the infinite is on the battlefield it
has all the activated abilities of all
artifacts in your graveyard
so with trazin on the battlefield and
the one ring in your graveyard trasen
gets the one Rings activated ability
there's two things to keep in mind
the best thing Transit only takes the
activated ability so that triggered
ability that would make you lose life at
the beginning of your upkeep forget
about it
however because trasin is a creature he
does get Summoning Sickness so he can't
use the Ring's ability straight away
still if you're going down the artifact
Commander route tresin is excellent
the other necron we need to talk about
is America the traveler there's five
minor four four has lord of the pyron
legion
whenever American attacks you may cast
an artifact spell from your hand or your
graveyard by paying life equal to its
Mana value rather than paying its minor
cost
okay so why this card
well the problem is the one ring is a
very good card and while yes it has
indestructible it can still be shut down
with exiling effects and one way we can
look to keep it out of Exile is by
making sure we can either move it to the
graveyard or bounce it back to our hand
and with Andra Care on the battlefield
we can safely sacrifice our one ring
with a number of sacrifice spells in
response to an exiling effect and then
cast it from the graveyard with anurac's
ability and because we cast it from the
graveyard we also get protection from
everything similarly Emery lurker off
the lock lets us cast artifact cards
from our graveyard meaning once again we
get the protection from every think
ability as we cast the card from the
graveyard Emery is a three Mana one two
that costs one less for each artifact we
control and when she enters the
battlefield we Mill four cards and she
has tap choose Target artifact card in
your graveyard you may cast that card
this turn
Emery is not only a great artifact
Commander she also goes into any
artifact deck running blue
our final budget card to talk about on
this list is drafner founder of latnam
this two Mana two One lets us return an
artifact we control back to our hand for
Just Two mana and for three and a tap we
can copy Target artifact spell
so instead of just sending the one ring
to the graveyard we can simply bounce it
back to our hand and if we have one of
our flash artifacts in play we can
constantly trigger the protection
ability whenever we need it
it's also great to know that the bounce
ability doesn't require drafner to tap
so we can always have that ability up
and ready to use even if drafner has
summoning sickness or if he's tapped
because of the copy ability
so there we have it 12 mostly budget
cards that pair excellently with the one
ring if you need some more ideas for
Budget cards that you should be checking
out be sure to watch this video here
don't forget to leave a like and let me
know in the comments down below if I
missed any awesome wandering cards
thanks for watching and I'll see you
guys next time